dans quel pays on paye le plus d'impôts
la France aurait championne de la
pression fiscale 45% du PIB pour chaque
reproduit le gouvernement récupère 45
cents c'est beaucoup la moyenne de
l'OCDE est à 34 ça nous place deuxième
mondiale juste derrière le Danemark sauf
que c'est plus compliqué que ça pour
l'imposition des salaires c'est les
Belges les champions 53% pour toucher
1000 euros il faut en payer le double
bar portant plus que la moyenne de
l'OCDE pour les taxes sur l'héritage
c'est les Coréens jusqu'à 50% même pour
vos proches en 2021 à la mort du PDG de
Samsung la famille devait dix milliards
de dollars à l'état pour payer il a
fallu se séparer des 23000 œuvres d'art
et pour la TVA en France avec nos 20% on
est 19e en Europe loin derrière les 27%
de la Hongrie mais plus besoin d'avoir
peur avec les bons outils comme axonaute
les impôts n'y pensent même pas ils ont
développé un logiciel de gestion complet
et intuitif facture de vie compta
marketing ça n'a jamais été aussi facile
et c'est français pensez-y la prochaine
fois que vous vous demandez